[Music]  it takes more than guns to kill a man  you think i'm your enemy  i am your enemy  but your enemy won't be gone when you  kill me  your brother is still in prison  your twin brother was an anarchist  my brother was a revolutionary  where is he  cameraman is my brother  he will last 10 minutes in the street  knowing what he knows  this  is a battleground  who's the contact  russia goodbye tell me so when is this  gonna happen it has happening for a  thousand years  we had a deal  your brother can expose everything  i have done what is mine to do  the world is watching what happens here  it's on  is he here now i would light myself on  fire  how come no one is hiding themselves on  fire  where's my brother  [Music]  [Music]  you